so we're talking about friday night
lights and football let's get a check of
our forecast now as we look towards the
weekend with ted yeah weekend looks
pretty good for all of us winds will
pick up a little for tomorrow but we're
keeping around that haze outside right
now as you can see from our tower camera
remember how thick that haze was
yesterday not so bad outside right now
we had it this morning but it cleared
out a little this afternoon however that
smoke advisory still remains in place
until sunday moderate air quality
however smoke is on the unhealthy
category but this really applies to
those of you with bronchitis or asthma
this is the time to just stay indoors
and do your exercising indoors rather
than outside 97 centennial hills right
now 88 in summer 92 for the lakes
currently 95 for downtown it is so nice
not to see triple digits in the
afternoon in this valley forecast right
96 in green valley 96 for
henderson 92 for rhodes ranch
unfortunately that's going to change by
the time we get to late in the weekend
and definitely next week wait till you
see the forecast 90 for indian springs
94 for prompt 96 for boulder city here
the areas with the triple digits of
course those of you in laughlin and of
course out in death valley at this hour
so dry conditions here future cast shows
this low that's off the coast that's
going to traverse to the north and what
that does is going to kick up our
southwest winds and give us some breezy
winds on saturday we're going to remain
dry though that's going to then move off
towards the area to the midwest upper
midwest by early next week winds
tomorrow like we said with that low are
going to pick up especially the midday
and afternoon hours where we'll see
those winds up to 20 at times and those
gusts could get up to 30 to even 35
especially down at the lake so we'll
keep our eye on those winds it will be a
breezy day for tomorrow 78 degrees
overnight hazy skies a comfortable
morning 99 for tomorrow so warming up
just a little bit but still below
average hazy and breezy tomorrow those
gusts like we said will be up to 30. if
you're going to mount charleston a lot
of you like to go to
lee canyon i don't blame you it's great
up there 74 degrees for tomorrow so it's
going to be comfortable but breezy so
we'll see those gusts also up to 30. if
you're going to the lake for tomorrow
now here's the deal 102 will be hot
windy and hot with those gusts that'll
be higher at 35 miles per hour we could
see one to two foot waves so that means
very choppy water for tomorrow so keep
that in mind make sure you wear the life
vest for sure because we're going to get
some pretty good pretty good waves for
tomorrow breezy winds for tomorrow with
that haze
each day gets hotter after that next
week oh yeah we bring back the heat as
we start to wrap up august temperatures
come very close to records thursday and
friday next week and more wind later on
in the week for next week that's your
most accurate forecast denise over here